For the first one, we just get 31,000. For 3.1 times 10 to the 10, we get this
much longer number. It's 3, 1, and then 9 0s. This is 31 billion, in fact. For
this last one, 3.1 times 10 to the 21, we get a kind of funny answer though.
When I type this in, and then press Enter, we get 3.1 I don't know what this
means. Well this is actually just how the calculator shows, 3.1 times 10 to the
21st. This e is not the special number that we met in the last lesson. E here
just stands for exponent. And it means the exponent of 10 is 21. And if there's
a positive sign here, that's just to distinguish this from negative 21. Some
calculator show this differently. So check yours to see what it displays, when
you enter the same number. Also as a challenge, see if you can guess how you'd
write this number in the same format as these other two we already saw. How
many digit's do you think it has?